SPEAKER: So far, we've
covered many aspects
of using Cloud Operations
to improve the observability
and reliability of your services
running on Google Cloud.
But how should you approach
setting up and using a suite
as your cloud footprint grows?
Today, we'll look
at some enterprise
best practices that you can
use to get the most value out
of Cloud Operations.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
Before we start, let's
take a step back and answer
this simple question.
Why do we do all
of these things?
What are we trying
to achieve, overall,
when using a suite
like Cloud Operations?
Ultimately, we're after
three main objectives.
The first one is to make sure
that our services are secure
and that we comply with
policies and regulations that
are specifically
relevant in our context.
That means we need
to manage things
like data access
and an audit trail.
The second one is
the objective we've
talked about in just
about every episode,
keeping our users happy.
That means we need to know
if user experience degrades,
hopefully by using SLOs,
and what to do about it.
The final goal is
managing the capacity
required to run our
services while ensuring
that we optimize for cost.
With that said, we'll
tackle best practices
for setting up and using
Cloud Operations by focusing
on these three key areas.
The first one, and the
one we'll focus on today,
will be best practices
for the enterprise.
We'll cover setting up
a centralized logging
and monitoring environment,
ensuring an audit trail,
and configuring data
retention and access.
The next episode will address
best practices for using
Cloud Monitoring specifically.
We'll get into what to
monitor, how to do it,
how to manage alerts, and how to
optimize your monitoring costs.
The final episode on this
topic will cover best practices
for Cloud Logging.
We'll get into what
and how to log,
how to use the logs
your services generate,
and how to optimize
your logging costs.
This is going to be a lot,
but I think you're ready.
Let's get into it.
Let's start by talking about
enterprise best practices.
The first recommendation
is to centralize
monitoring, auditing,
and observability data
in a single place.
For services running
on Google Cloud,
we recommend using Cloud
Operations to do just that.
Having this information
in a single repository
with easy cross-team
access greatly
improves practices like
architecture design,
incident response, and
root cause analysis.
For example, if I know the
historical reliability track
record of my dependencies, I can
better architect my own service
to meet my reliability
objectives.
At the same time, I can do a
better job of incident response
if I can see whether
the services I depend on
are having an incident.
It's really difficult
to do things like this
without having all this
information in a single place.
The second recommendation
is to ensure
that a clear and
easily accessible
audit trail exists
for your services.
This means using
cloud audit logs
to help answer questions
like who did what,
where, and when in your Google
Cloud projects, and managing
IAM controls to limit who has
access to view audit logs.
We've covered using audit logs
in detail in another video.
We'll link to it
in the show notes.
As you make audit log
configuration changes,
use a test Google Cloud
project to validate them
before propagating to developer
and production projects.
When considering how you
grant access to audit
logs across the
organization, we recommend
using a least privilege approach
to granting permissions.
We'll link to specific examples
of that in the episode notes.
Note that data access audit
logs are off by default,
except for BigQuery.
When you enable new
Google Cloud Services,
evaluate whether or
not to enable data
access audit logs
for that new service.
The final recommendation
for enterprises
is to thoughtfully manage
log retention and analysis.
Consider the various
retention needs
for compliance requirements,
security and access analytics,
and event analytics.
We'll link to
documentation explaining
specific considerations for each
scenario in the episode notes.
The first way to do this
is by using log views.
You can use log
views to control who
has access to logs
within your log buckets
based on your needs
and requirements.
Custom log views provides
you with a granular way
to control access to the
logs in your log buckets.
You can also carefully
control log retention
by using project-level
or aggregated sinks
to export logs to BigQuery,
Cloud Storage, and Pub/Sub
for analytics, archival, or
consumption by other systems.
Each of these do have
their own mechanisms
for controlling
retention and access,
and you should
carefully consider those
as you plan your
retention strategy.
Thanks for joining me today.
We covered best practices
for setting up and using
Cloud Operations
in the enterprise,
including centralizing data,
managing an audit trail,
and configuring data retention.
I hope these
recommendations help
you keep your services
secure and your users happy.
In our next episode, we'll
tackle best practices
for using Cloud Monitoring.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]